anthony pitched a couple of times on the
just completed road trip he had a start
he also had a relief appearance and it
was just one inning that was his
downfall on the road last start he gave
up four runs in that morning the big hit
the home run by mitch moreland then he
came in relief in that game in houston
after nate pearson started it have one
bad inning gave up the three-run home
run little hooper and glitching's going
to get over there and make the catch uh
segur loses that long battle with
anthony k
first down to the inning
he went after it and went around he
appealed down to third and okay gets the
call
harper strikes out on a breaking ball
got him well it took him a long time but
he gets out of it after lead off walk he
leaves mccutchen stranded in first we'll
go to the bottom of the first nose score
aaron nola look at these numbers in
eight starts a 359 earned average 53
strikeouts in just eight base on balls
all season long and he comes into this
game i think upset because
atlanta treated him very rudely the last
time he pitched he threw four innings
against the braves and they rocked him
for five hits and five earned runs
swinging a miss he threw back-to-back
change-ups to get simeon
and one out here in the bottom of the
first that'll bring up vladimir guerrero
jr who homered last night for the only
run of the game for the jays
there's a deep drive to right center
this one's gonna go get out of here gone
bloody guerrero
number 10
his fifth opposite field home run
that might be the most important number
he's going the other way with some
authority here's a swing and a breaking
ball and he gretchek hits one deep to
center going back on it is o'double he's
on the track
and he makes the catch a loud out number
three
one run in the inning on the one hit the
homer by guerrero his tenth and we'll go
to the second blue jays lead one number
three second straight inning the
phillies have the lead off man aboard
called strike three right on the outside
corner he located that one
called strike three nice job by kay as
he pitches around to hit batter to start
the inning
lourdes guriel the batter now 205 hit
him ground ball fair ball past the third
baseman down the left-field line vizio's
headed to third he's being waved home
and there'll be no throw to the plate as
curiel is going to go to third ball got
away from a time the shortstop and
that'll be an air but the blue jays get
a run
base hit for maguire glorious jogs home
reese maguire with his first rbi of the
season gives the blue jays a three
nothing lead three
swinging the ground ball towards the
middle sugar has got it runs to the bag
steps on second throws to first there's
the double play two runs in the inning
for the jays on three hits an error
one and two on maton the pitch swung on
and hit hard to left coming in again is
guriel he won't get this one as it will
drop in for a hit
and nick maton if at first it doesn't
succeed try again
in the air to right oscar took a step
back and now he's going to recover he
makes the play
segura got jammed on the first pitch and
ta oscar and his first move was back
got it
second time that k has struck out bryce
harper for a third straight inning the
phillies get the lead off man on
and they leave him on base
one ball two strikes
swag gonna miss change up it's the best
off speed pitch he has tonight because
the curveball's not working at this
point but he gets the first batter and
the pitch
and that's a strike on the inside corner
is a grichik trying to check on the
swing again went around
this time on a change-up that was in off
the plate
and it'll bring up brad miller
miller strikes out for a second time
this time swinging that's six strikeouts
make up for his lack of command but he's
going to get out of it once again the
phillies will leave another base runner
they'll go to the bottom of the fourth
anthony k and the blue jays have a three
nothing lead kingery is in right field
bryce harper
walked out of the phillies dugout down
the left field line and went into the
clubhouse he was packing his bats in we
have no indication of
why he's out of the game
check swing
and he went
and nola picks up his fourth
strikeout there's a base hit for tolez
he stayed on that changeup gurilla had
to wait to make sure it wasn't caught so
he advances to 90 feet good at bet
and a strike three called
right on the inside part of the plate
two strikeouts in the inning five
overall for nola
yeah now that's pitching there
swung on hit sharply right at maton it's
short he'll go the short way to second
and they'll force the runner out at
second base and that'll do it for the
jays no runs two hits two left after
four complete it's the jays three in the
phillies
not that important as maitan strikes up
another high fastball and
bergen strikes him out
there's a little looper that's going to
drop into the glove of marcus simeon
bergen with another good inning of work
he leaves a base runner on we'll go to
the bottom of the fifth the shet's in
scoring position for t oscar hernandez
he has walked stole the base and popped
out
bouncing ball toward third and boom
can't come up with it
the ball
stayed down didn't hop up for him and i
don't know if he got a glove on it but
he couldn't come up with it cleanly and
take oscar's aboard now randall griczyk
will have a chance to add to the blue
jays lead they lead it three to nothing
runners at the corners just one out
runner's not going anywhere the pit
swung on ground ball towards short
mayton to his left he's got it flips to
segura one onto first double play
and a huge double play for erin nolta
to get out of trouble here in the fifth
inning third pitcher of the night for
the blue jays will be aj cole
off speed pitch and kingery strikes out
one down
they've added some pitchers and
just kind of got moved down the depth
chart and now they've needed him in here
he drops one in there and gets riamuta
rio luto's not so sure it was a strike
he's got some words for dan iasonia
wrecking ball
the shet playing in the shift makes an
easy play of it aj cole
a couple of strikeouts gives up a base
hit and nothing more three-nothing ball
game the blue jays lead it phillies have
a runner at third one out for the number
nine enter nick maton
nathan strikes out for a second time
third strikeout for aj cole dean segura
to the plate representing the tying run
it's a three nothing game
got it he dispatches segura on three
pitches good job by chadwood the
phillies strand two more it's
interesting with guriel at the plate in
the base open it looks like they're
going to pitch to him
pops this one up into shallow center may
tom back segura there and they drop it
and it falls in between them and gritsy
comes in to score the phillies have not
had a good night in the field jordan
romano will take over the mound he's
been hot he's given up one run over his
last seven appearances
that covers seven innings he's dropped
that opponent's batting average
on the ground
bishop will go to second and that's the
ball game the blue jays win it four to
nothing with their second shutout of the
season and that evens the series at a
game of peace yeah great pitching all
the way around